[Music]
we have developed platform to build
wearable health solutions that can track
people at home and do things that they
usually do in hospital or they're not
done at all so what you have today is on
one hand yet consumer devices are very
comfortable but on a very accurate on
the other hand you have medical devices
they're not comfortable at all and so
what we do what bite fights we combine
both or vision is to enable wearable
health we want to make sure that
everybody can use our platform and our
dream is that every medical verbal will
be developed on the whiteflies platform
to make that possible we collaborate
with Android things because Android
already build a whole community for app
development and they made possible that
everybody that wants to build an app and
bring it to the community can do so from
the start when we started building a
byte flash platform we didn't want to
reinvent the wheel so for us you want to
focus really on the things where we can
make a difference and tap into existing
solutions existing technologies existing
platforms that do it much better than we
do and that's a very important part of
using Android things is that we can tap
into the infrastructure but also the
stack that is already set up talking
about security is talking about privacy
talking about over-the-air updates that
we don't have to do ourselves as well
because that's something we're Google
and Android and Android thinks is very
strong at and then we can focus on
accurate data collection the seamless
collection to the cloud and signal
processing which are our strong points
and we don't have to worry too much
about the other parts while still
knowing that we get very good quality
then we integrated Android things in our
docking stations which you can consider
as a small computer that sits at the
bedside of the patient so basically
where the sensor for the full day or for
a longer period and at a given moment
they plug it into a docking station and
because of Android thinks it connects to
the cloud easily every button that a
patient needs to press as one too many
we do automatic updates patient doesn't
even know it we can deploy as many units
as we wants we have the whole Google
cloud we have the whole tensorflow
technology that is all embedded in
Android things so it's a very strong
framework where you can you just piggy
back to the tool that we want and build
our own technology on top of that
sometimes you want to develop everything
from scratch and that's actually the
worst thing you can do we designed our
platform in a way that we handle that
data with care and then it's HIPAA
compliant but because of Android things
we have better control to make sure that
security and privacy is controlled from
the moment it leaves the device and it
leaves the patient until it gets to the
cloud and until it's being processed
there we have the vision that in five to
ten years there's gonna be an abundance
of Health wearables that gonna change
healthcare and gonna change health of
everyone around we want that these
health wearables are built in by flash
platform that's gonna allow to transform
healthcare from being 99% curing today
to hopefully 99% prevention